CRYSTAL BALL.
I WILL SAY HE IS A LIAR.
I WILL SAY HE CHEATED EVEN
BEFORE IT HAPPENS.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> THE ARGUMENT, WHY DON'T YOU
JUST WAIT AMOUNTS TO THIS.
WHY DON'T YOU JUST LET HIM CHEAT
AND ONE MORE ELECTION?
WHY NOT LET HIM CHEAT JUST ONE
MORE TIME?
WHY NOT LET HIM HAVE FOREIGN
HELP JUST ONE MORE TIME?
THAT IS WHAT THAT ARGUMENT
AMOUNTS TO.
>> Sean: HERE WITH REACTION
REPUBLICAN SENATOR FROM GEORGIA
DOUG COLLINS, I'M SORRY, THEY
MADE THE WRONG DECISION.
HOW ARE YOU, CONGRESSMAN?
GOOD TO SEE YOU.
>> GOOD TO SEE YOU, SHAWN.
>> Sean: I'M STILL NOT HAPPY
WITH YOUR CAMP.
>> I UNDERSTAND.
>> Sean: OKAY, HE IS A LIAR.
HE HAS A PROVEN LIAR.
WE SEE THAT DEVIN NUNES TOLD THE
TRUTH AND THE CONGENITAL LIAR
DOES WHAT HE DOES AND LIES.
HOW DOES HE GET AWAY WITH IT AND
NOW THE ENTIRE DEMOCRATIC PARTY
OVER THE CLIFF WITH HIM.
>> I THINK THIS IS HIS BIGGEST
MISTAKE.
FOR A WHILE HIS LIES ONLY LET
HIMSELF DOWN THAT PATH.
WE TALKED ABOUT HIM BEFORE HE
CAN'T SPELL TRUTH MUCH LESS TELL
IT.
HE'S CROSSING THE LINE.
HE'S TAKING THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY
OVER THE LINE WITH HIS LIES.
THE INTERESTING THING IN WHAT HE
SAID A MINUTE AGO SHOULD SCARE
EVERYBODY.
THIS PRESIDENT DESERVES MUCH
BETTER BECAUSE THIS PRESIDENT IS
DOING WHAT IS RIGHT.
ADAM SCHIFF IS SAYING FAIRNESS
AND JUSTICE ARE AT THE EPITOME
OF STAYING BACK AND WATCHING A
CLOCK AND A CALENDAR.
HE IS SAYING IT DOESN'T MATTER
ANYMORE ABOUT FAIRNESS.
AS LONG AS WE GET TO DO THE TIME
FRAME WE GET TO DO IT ON.
ADAM SCHIFF HAS A LOT TO BE
ACCOUNTED FOR BUT NOW HOTLY
HITCHING HIMSELF TO IT BUT THE
ENTIRE DEMOCRATIC CAUCUS OF THAT
LIFE AND THEY WILL PAY A PRICE.
THE PRESIDENT WILL BE ELECTED
BECAUSE HE IS DOING WHAT THE
AMERICANS WANT.
THAT IS BEING PROVEN TRUTH OVER
AND OVER AGAIN.
HE CANNOT KEEP LYING ABOUT THIS
BECAUSE THE PEOPLE ARE SEEN
THROUGH IT.
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE IS
FINALLY STARTING TO SEE IT.
>> Sean: IT IS ALL COME FROM
THE UNVERIFIABLE CLINTON BOUGHT
AND PAID FOR DIRTY RUSSIAN
DOSSIER WAS THE ENTIRE MARK.
NOW I MUST HAS THE ENTIRE
DEMOCRATIC CAUCUS.
WELL, FIRST THING THEY
ELIMINATED BRIBERY QUID PRO QUO
AND EXTORTION.
THAT JUST DISAPPEARED.
NO OBSTRUCTION OF JUSTICE AND
ABUSE OF POWER.
OBSTRUCTION OF JUSTICE BECAUSE
YOU ACTUALLY SEEK REMEDY IN A
COURT WHICH IS ACTUALLY ALLOWED
IN THE ROLE OF THE JUDICIARY.
SO THE QUESTION IS, WHERE DOES
THIS GO?
>> WHERE IT GOES IS WE WILL
START OFF TOMORROW WITH THESE
IMPEACHMENT ARTICLES.
I TELL YOU WHAT IS HAPPENING
HERE.
ABUSE OF POWER IS THE MOST
AMBIGUOUS, VAGUE REFERENCE TO AN
IMPEACHMENT THAT YOU COULD EVER
HAVE.
YOU CAN MAKE ANYTHING YOU WANT.
YOU KNOW WHY THE PRESIDENT GOT
UP AND WORE A RED TIE?
THAT IS ABUSIVE POWER.
IT WORKS WELL OR OVER FORMER
PRESIDENT ERIC'S WALLER.
AND REMOVING AN AMBASSADOR.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT PLANET HE IS
LIVING ON BUT THAT IS NOT AN
IMPEACHABLE.
BUT THE ABUSE OF POWER WILL GIVE
YOU THAT.
THE OTHER ISSUE OBSTRUCTION OF
JUSTICE, CONGRESS AFTER 72 DAYS,
GIVE ME A BREAK.
HERE IS THE PROBLEM, SEAN AND
YOU HAVE NOT HINTED ON THIS YET.
THIS IS THE PART WHERE THE
COMMITTEE AND INTELLIGENCE
ACTUALLY TAPPED INTO PHONE
RECORDS.
THEY FOUND PHONE RECORDS AND
WENT AT IT AND FOUND
DEVIN NUNES, AND MADE SOMEBODY
ON THE COMMITTEE DO IT.
IT IS EITHER SCHIFF BUT THEY
WOULD NOT PROVE THAT.
THEY WANT TO SMEAR THEM.
THEY WANT TO SMEAR THEM, SEAN.
THIS IS A DRIVE BY NOTHING BUT A
SMEAR CATEGORY BECAUSE THEY HAVE
NOTHING ELSE IN THE SCHIFF
REPORT.
WHAT DO THEY DO?
LET'S ME OF THE COLLEAGUES.
WE ARE INVOLVED SO FAR IN
CONGRESS WHERE ADAM SCHIFF IS
LEADING A CORRUPT INVESTIGATION.
>> Sean: ACTUALLY NEEDED
IMPEACHMENT.
DO YOU THINK THE DEMOCRATS, WILL
THEY VOTE AND GO FORWARD WITH
THIS INSANITY?